[Music]
we shoot this show in los angeles uh
uh-huh a fantastic city yes and um
she is she is my lady
really yeah ellie is my lady oh that's
weird uh
well this was a big story here there was
a bear on the loose in a suburban los
angeles neighborhood yesterday the local
news was all over this story as you can
imagine crazy footage take a look at
this the bear it's a giant looks like a
brown bear to me because he's brown
yeah
but he's climbing over fences he's going
into people's yards he was wandering all
over the place
yeah now animal control did arrive they
tranquilized the bear he's fine released
him back into the wild okay
but we have been asked to remind
everyone who's watching uh summer is
coming okay and with summer coming the
bears will be out and around if you
encounter a bear whatever you do do not
disturb it
okay just let the bear do what it does
until animal control arrives i think
that's it's really the only sensible
uh oh what fun
okay okay wait a minute hold on hold on
hold on we've got a bear we have a bear
in the studio somehow don't move guys
okay don't move guys guys okay he's head
this way okay just take it easy
just let him okay let him do what he's
gonna do
just let him get back up
leave him alone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]